What. Insects do for Africa and let's talk about food for a child. Yeah OK. So what or what.
What can insects do for Africa for food. You know. So should I say I have no.
Yeah OK I can just see if you are just I'll get ignored. Yeah OK.
Inspectors can do a lot of things for a wide range of things for for Africa for Africa
and we called it to go insects can do a wide range of things for Africa not just for Africa
but for mankind on the planet that may give City dissing and important examples
and one is pulling it that's pulling it that's like bees. Honeybees.
While to be carpenter to be say a wide range of feel sick this play a critical role in food security.
At least seventy to forty percent of our crops critical crops and and fruits and as it plants require pollination.
So if these have to disappear tomorrow that. The. Food security situation. Globally would be very so shaky.
This is one important old insects play for mankind the as a result I think is also insect is for food and feet.
So about two billion people globally. Traditionally consume insects as a food source as a protein source.
High quality protein source. And.
So the insect insects also play a significant role in food chain in the food web chain.
So tremendous number of amphibians. Birds. Chicken. Reptiles.
They depend exclusively on insects for their fried so this is a tremendous contribution what insects do globally for
animals humans and so on and about two thousand. Species of insects are consumed in one way or another.
Globally out of that about a certain drove that consumed in Africa so.
Central Africa southern parts of Africa is a hotspot for.
Insects for food
and feed so that's a second large impact what insects can do for us for humans a certain important been officially
picked is that there are while there are how do you feel insects to humans
and animals as vectors to diseases of transmission of diseases.
Also a wide range of insects also play a critical role in our environment as pre-date there's predictors of.
That that predators of as it harmful insects.
There are insecticides if you don't most get those that transmitted diseases.
There are a spider such feed on mosquitoes that there are predators that also feed all. Insects sat out.
How do you feel to crops. So they plays that for you as a play significant only an hour or so. Well being.
You say because we only started to begin to understand the meaning of insects. So.
So I think more and more now people globally have begun understanding that all of insects particularly because of the.
What is called colony collapse syndrome or B.C. In North America and. In Europe.
So more and more of the general public. Has Begun understanding this.
So I would think that I think the next century will be really focused on insects
and not only because of the role they play in agriculture the role they play in human
and animal disease is a role they play in the food chain
but also because of their associated impact on climate change as climate change becomes more and more evident.
And temperatures rise. Begin to rise in Africa and in Europe. Indeed. Notice I made a car.
What that will do is a shift also in their distribution of insects
and disease transmitting insect is from the tropics to what used to be the temperate of September at climates
and what happened. Saying is. Those diseases that are considered as. Poor. Monster diseases are tropical diseases.
Neglected Diseases become relevant to the temperate climate. And so.
At the end of the day I think then the planet has to address also this so-called neglected diseases that are
transmitted by insects. So what you say is that knowledge scientific knowledge on insects is of the utmost importance.
So scientific then that makes it is that scientific knowledge and more investment on science
and technology dealing with insects because. Really a make it and break it. Situation for the well being of mankind.
So I think they were led to have. To prepared now to focus and invest more on insects and related arthropods.
And the role they play for the well being. Go to the. Mankind on the planet and and animals that we depend on.
Their Institute actually is a sort of. Introduce fool offer here and treasures.
Can you tell me a little bit about the kind of. Treasures you have in your wrist to sew for all this point of view and.
The growing important a few sects and related arthropods for mankind.
Mine is Station the International Center of insect physiology and ecology which is a unique center.
That is exclusively focusing on.
Insects and dealing with environmental hurdles and human health and animal hers
and plan tells us the role it plays becomes even more critical for not just for Africa
but for the rest of the world because we have a lot of threats because of our location in Africa because of our focus
in Africa. We know how to deal with a myriad of insects and the diseases say they cause we know how to utilize.
And number of. Beneficial insects. We have discovered and and created innovative voice of how to do loses.
From natural products from what Africa has to offer based on also look at all knowledge
and bringing science into the local knowledge. And saw. Also I think the diversity of Africa has a diversity of.
Plants the diversity of insects South Africa has the diversity of wildlife as our own we play for Africa
and the rest of the planet would be. Would be. Critical.
And very very important and so we were going to International Center of insect physiology and ecology.
Would increasingly play a critical role. At the center of all of this.
Could you uncover a few of those treasure few have in your institute what kind of.
So let me give you an example on how.
Is place a critical road for example says he flies are very very important place this. For livestock.
And also also they transmitted diseases also to humans. Saw a large area large amount of areas of.
In many countries in Africa. Are infested with says he flies making it not inhabitable. For animals and humans.
But so many years ago scientists discovered of made a keen.
And very important observation that some wildlife like zebras
and like water barks they can live without being affected in heavily. Infested areas.
This is a flame just day that's where cattle kind of set right where humans can sleep.
And yet those areas are very important for Thailand.
I've learned we can we can utilize so was a serious of experiments and research. Scientists discover the reason why.
Zebras and some of these wildlife can live without any problem and says they fly areas.
And that is because they emits they generate order from their bodies which is composed of chemicals natural came across
other exuded from the bodies of the Sun months.
So we have been characterized the chemical structure of the chemistry behind it and so on and now today.
Fast forward we developed a color system.
That emits chemicals that that are manufactured based on the chemical structure of the natural chemical that comes out
of this wild animals and. We can protect the cattle. So a color system.
That basically emits the same chemicals as wildlife.
Those are there's one illustration where we can actually make use of the natural of nature
and wildlife to solve the problem couldn't couldn't leave the critical problem.
So there are many examples of like that that has disappeared has generated over the years. You also developed a.
Quite ecological system of and hand seeing the harvest of for example mice or are such was my god. What did you do.
So another example is also that.
For example in crops basically in this step in the groups that are critical for food security like me is one of the
major problem space but only in system borders. To control the same waters in a more.
Ecology environmentally friendly way and affordable way for the farmers.
Without spraying chemicals chemicals to control the pest.
We developed a technology where to plant south naturally have chemicals to control to repel.
The pests and to trap so pissed.
When there are entire crop was mis or sort of them or as a cereals we can control the paste.
This is very environmentally friendly. It is affordable. So you farmers can do it. It's also.
It's also more sustainable. It's healthy for the environment. But while we're doing it.
We made accidental discoveries this appellant plants truck plants also control a very very important parasitic weed
called slag. So that was a huge huge discovery for us we were not working on strike.
Or working on their own sticks but then we managed to. To control another extremely important food security parasite.
But the beauty of this also is. It does several hours of things it. Improves soil fertility.
Eight provides high quality feed for any months it improves over all the soil structure and fertility.
And also in it increases productivity and recently we discovered last wish it did was it.
This was this technology is a push pull technology.
Maize plants actually become also healthier and they don't have a aflatoxin.
Which is a very bad his was a very bad toxin produce had by far the fungus a spurt of genius.
And we managed to tackle a wide range of major consequence for African farmers
and this normally can be adopted anywhere else in the planet for as little as it crops as well not just serious MS
and sort of government as a staple crops. It sounds terrific. It sounds as a major improvement to the major technology.
This is a major breakthrough some major breakthrough
and I think what gives me pleasure is also this innovation discovery was made in Africa by African technical team.
So this is also indications that actually we can generate Lucian's a very source first sustainable solution affordable
solution for farmers that can be adopted and boost productivity and.
Improve the whole environmental health as a whole this is exciting. This is absolutely exciting.
What we need to do now is find relevant partners is to live on the Mount of fund to scale out this all across Africa
because Sub-Saharan Africa has a major stem board a problem. Space problem.
As a major aflatoxin problem major strike a problem. Major soil fertility problem.
So was one technology you can sort of all of this.
I can't think of any As a technology in recent years in agricultural sciences.
And herds that can do all the seen in one very sustainable way environmentally friendly way. And uplift people.
Lives in a very short period of time in one season of adapting that technology you can already transform people's lives
in one in one season cropping season and there is nothing that excites me more than months on these modes
and translating that science and technology in product.
And seeing the impact that I thought we would in one season on families and communities
and it sounds as if you're in a hurry to introduce this very. Absolutely. In a hurry.
So sometimes I drive people crazy. Because this technology.
We know that it can transform people see lives in one season. It's needed all across Africa just like you started.
So why can't we.
The global community invest significant amount of money
and effort to eradicate it uses technology eradicate the parasitic weed a strike which is literally Robin livelihoods
after farmers and people. So we have and why.
What makes me impatient and in a hurry because I know this technology can change lives
and we cannot take it to the pharmacist fast enough.
And plenty enough to make significant improvement in people's lives. That is one of the most frustrating.
You can encounter but then I am determined to be as it was my team
and partners to to reach many many many farmers with this up to now we have reached Only hundred ten thousand farmers
in three countries and saying we can do a lot more than this.
What kind of future do you see for Africa in terms of let's say from a trickle logical scientific point a few.
The the future of Africa is very bright the future of Africa is very bright and wide.
I say that because we have a lot of resources we have natural resources. The gift of natural resources we have.
The diversity of funny. We have diversity of plants we have a lot of natural resources like. Like minerals.
And and as a value in materials. And I think in science so Africa is heaven for new discoveries waiting to happen.
I think we can find solutions for many many of our constraints so the future is very bright
but then Africa are fast to believe in itself has to believe in its people has to invest in its people.
The most important and the most valuable resource for any country any country and to see its people.
And I think on people who don't countries who don't invest in science and technology.
Who don't invest in the education of people they are doomed to not to develop. So our future has to design.
So in the next several also declared Africa is predicted to have. The youngest. Population on the planet.
So this population there has to be utilised effectively. So if we do all that if we invest in science and technology.
If we find solutions from what we have already.
And if we believe in ourselves in our capacity the future of Africa is extremely bright and I think.
It takes is it has been shown already that Africa in the last decade is on the rise and many of.
The I thinks at least seven out of ten growing the economy started was enough.
You know on the planet that is a lot of things we can do but I think the future is very very bright
and in sexual play a large role in that there and so the future is bright and. Investment in science and technology.
And the role also insights can play both in seed ensued in nutrition in House is also extremely bright and I think
and a diversity of insects also within the continent is also among It is three years
and has to use it has to Violet has to make use of it.
Not only for the continent
but also as a gift to the rest of the littles here which you say that we are sort of entering an era an era for where
insects are going to play a major role in you know the destination of you meant going to I may make it a little bit big
but yet you know what you are talking about earlier.
I believe Russia actually we are as more and more knowledge
and awareness becomes available to the general public to say I think we are entering into a kid into a million in where
insecticide.
An important part of our well being and and boy is in danger
and got its consumption main source of proteins for the animals but also for the humans but also I think they.
Play also a critical role in their having a will sustainable environment and so there's certain that.
Sex will play and will continue to play extremely cliff not only in mankind. So what role will go which was.
I want I think I want people to understand where in. Turning. The age of insects.
The importance of insects in many different ways out of environment in.
Decomposing waste to clean up our environment in contributing to our food and.
Did nutrition and security in contributing in our house in contributing and as so son of a food source to.
So this is the edge of insects I've been to them.
And Africa is going to play a major role and Africa is going to play a significant role not only for itself.
But for the rest of the planet. Africa is not going to be just a continent but receiving aid.
But also to be recalled and. As a continent that is actually making a difference for the rest of the wounded and.